FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY.
>> Bret: LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT
THE SITUATION.
GOOD EVENING, BRIT.
WHAT DO YOU OF ALL THIS TODAY?
>> I THINK IT'S INTERESTING THAT
THE CONGRESS JUMPED ON HER WITH
BOTH FEET, REALLY, AND GOT HER
TO ISSUE WHAT YOU CALLED AN
UNEQUIVOCAL APOLOGY.
THE QUESTION REMAINS NOW IS ANY
FURTHER ACTION WILL ENSUE.
YOU MAY RECALL WHEN CONGRESSMAN
STEVE KING OF IOWA, A HARD-CORE
CONSERVATIVE, HAD BEEN ACCUSED
OF RACIAL INSENSITIVITY AND
WORSE WAS CAUGHT IN A SIMILAR
SITUATION.
HE WAS STRIPPED BY THE
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP OF HIS
COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS.
MS. OMAR HAS A COVETED POSITION
AND SO FAR NO MOVE TO STRIP HER
OF ANY OF HER COMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS.
THE OTHER THING OF COURSE, BRET,
SHE DIDN'T EQUIVOCATE ON THE
APOLOGY WHEN SHE WENT ON TO TALK
ABOUT HOW SHE WAS REALLY BEING
CRITICAL OF THE INFLUENCE OF
LOBBYING.
LOBBYING, OF COURSE, BY ANOTHER
NAME FOR THE PETITIONING OF THE
GOVERNMENT FOR REDRESS OF
GRIEVANCES WHICH IS PROTECTED BY
THE FIRST AMENDMENT, SO ONE
WONDERS HOW PARTIAL GET WITH
THAT.
>> Bret: A LITTLE LATER IN THE
SHOW, WE HAVE A STORY WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND THE BLACKFACE
SCANDAL, THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
WITH ALLEGATIONS OF ASSAULTS.
ALL THE THINGS THAT DEMOCRATS
ARE DEALING WITH AND TRYING TO
DEAL WITH THEM QUICKLY.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE FRUITS OF
IDENTITY POLITICS.
WHEN YOU POSE AS THE PARTY MORE
SENSITIVE TO VARIOUS GROUPS, YOU
ARE VULNERABLE TO CHARGES THAT
YOU ARE NOT TENTATIVE ENOUGH.
THAT'S WHAT CAUGHT RALPH
NORTHAM, THE GOVERNOR OF
VIRGINIA, IN HIS SIGHTS.
OF COURSE, THE #MeToo MOVEMENT
MOVEMENT, SENSITIVITY TOWARDS
MISTREATMENT OF WOMEN, YOU HAVE
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR IN
TROUBLE OF THAT.
AND THE SITUATION IN VIRGINIA
LOOKS LIKE ONE WHERE YOU THOUGHT
THE GOVERNOR WAS GOING TO BE
GONE ABOUT TEN DAYS AGO IF IT
LOOKS LIKE HE'S THERE TO STAY.
AND IF HE STAYS, IT'S HARD TO
IMAGINE THAT HIS ATTORNEY
GENERAL, WHO WOULD BE THIRD IN
LINE IN SUCCESSION, WHO'S GOT
THE SAME PROBLEM AS THE GOVERNOR
HAS ABOUT A BLACKFACE INCIDENT
WHY HE WOULD GO, AND, OF COURSE,
JUST IN FAIRFAX WHO WAS ACCUSED
OF RAPE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT IS
ASKING FOR A FULL HEARING, IT'S
HARD TO IMAGINE HE WON'T GET
THAT.
LOOKS LIKE HE'S NOT GOING
ANYWHERE FOR A WHILE EITHER.
VIRGINIA WERE IT LOOK LIKE IF
YOU DAYS AGO THE THREE TOP
DEMOCRATS IN THE STATE MIGHT GO
DOWN, LOOKS LIKE THEY ARE GOING
TO BE THERE FOR A WHILE, BRET.
AT LEAST TO ME ANYWAY.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK ANYTHING
HAPPENS WITH REPS TENTATIVE
OMAR?
>> I THINK WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT
AND SEE.
I SUSPECTED THE DEMOCRATIC
LEADERSHIP WOULD LIKE TO LEAVE
THIS WHERE IT IS AND TREAT HER
APOLOGY AS SUFFICIENT TO LET HER
REMAIN IN HER COMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS.
AND IT'LL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHETHER THERE ARE FURTHER